always in this opening everything is
just in case oh but okay again bishop
takes g4 we have to remind ourselves is
not a threat because of knight takes f2
and uh
okay
get rid of that
and uh yeah knight f6
let's have a look how does that work out
so after the move
knight f6
and okay so what happens if
oh
what what what
does this what happened
[Laughter]
okay
all righty okay so so now we have to
find out yeah okay so what is going to
happen right if porn takes knight
let's uh let's how bishop takes knight
let's uh investigate those captures so
is this a well-known idea
to put the knight on f6 this is the
first
so
maybe
we probably must assume that they they
know about it
yeah so they probably know that it won't
come as a bolt from from the blue to
sergey karjakin but you know porn takes
night okay so what happens next so now
we go night takes yep night sorry flies
just hovering around in the studio so
knight takes porn
and uh
once
don takes bish ponte's night bishop
takes rook
knight takes oh
and then
that's this is this is really bad
this is bad and this is bad because the
you know the rooks generally fight
really well against
against uh
let's go like this bishop and knight in
an end game and that's because the rook
rooks are actually
very long-range moves
it's a long-range piece and it has the
capability to flick between the two
sides very easily and when you combine
this with past pawns on both sides of
the board it's just very dangerous